according to the dating app hinge 75 of
their users are looking for and ready
for a relationship there's a new book
it's called how to not die alone the
surprising science that will help you
find love and it applies concepts from
behavioral science to dating it's
written by logan yuri she's a behavioral
scientist and the director of
relationship science at hinge yes it is
a science apparently that's lesson
number one uh the book is terrific i
love it i actually want to give a copy
to a friend who i think is dating the
wrong person
you'll tell me if that's rude if you say
the name right now you'll just address
no
yeah go ahead
but the the i think the foundational
premise is really interesting which is
that love is not just a thing or a a
winning relationship is not something
that just happens by luck you have to
work for it and you show people how yes
exactly so love is natural we're born
knowing how to love but we are not born
knowing how to date dating is a skill
and you can get better at it and i will
teach you how to do that and so part of
getting better is first realizing what
kind of data you are you say there are
three types what are they i love the the
tendencies yes so i worked with clients
around the world they're all really
different but i was like there's
something they all have in common and it
was unrealistic expectations and so i
categorized them into the three types so
the first type is the romanticizer they
love love they're waiting for the soul
mate the meat cute and they expect love
to look a certain way if it feels like
work you're doing it wrong that's me
that's you okay yes hello my name is
gail go ahead we should talk about it
the second type is the maximizer i get a
lot of clients like this they have
unrealistic expectations of their
partner they think i like her but could
she be five percent hotter five percent
more ambitious they're just always
trying to find the next best thing and
then the third type which i've seen a
lot of during the pandemic is the
hesitator and they have unrealistic
expectations of themselves they're just
saying i'll date when i lose 10 pounds
i'll date when i have a new job it's
always i'm not ready to date yet they
think they have to be 100 ready before
they put themselves out there and there
never is a good time you say but yeah
a couple of many things stood out to me
number one i'm doing everything wrong
but you i want to take off some things
let's do it social media leads to
compare and despair
prince charming has morning breath
number one doesn't exist so look for
someone named larry never did that
before sit next to you rather than
across from your date and look for a
life partner not a prom date what do you
mean yeah so who's a prom date right
there's someone who looks good in photos
you want to dance the night away with
them maybe you want to have a little
kiss or more at the end of the night but
you don't think will this person pick up
my kids from the dentist and so it's
fine to look for a prom date that's
going to be light and fun but when
you're looking for the person you want
to spend your life with your criteria
have to change
you say great relationships are built
not discovered but what does that mean
so many people i work with they feel
like when they meet the perfect person
it'll just feel right right people say
this thing i know it when i see it well
actually relationships are built and so
that's very empowering because then you
can think i'll meet someone great and
build this great relationship with them
it's not about it feeling perfect from
the beginning when it comes to fairy
tales and romantic comedies yeah it
always starts with the spark yeah there
was a spark between us you say that the
spark is one of the most harmful ideas
to dating why so nate i've been looking
for the sparks i know that's why i said
i know i read this book i'm doing
everything wrong i mean i love the spark
too but this is what was happening i had
this one client in particular he would
go out on dates and he would say i met
this guy he was great we had a really
fun date i'm never going to see him
again i would say what are you talking
about that sounds like such a good date
he'd say oh i just didn't feel the spark
and that's why i say it's become such
this such a harmful idea in dating and
there's three main myths of the spark so
the first one is that
if you don't have the spark it'll never
grow and that's just not true right
people marry someone from work someone
from their office someone from the
building right the spark can grow over
time that's why you say go on second
date oh yes it doesn't seem right for
the first one yeah the first date people
are nervous some people just don't shine
on it so i'm reminded of the old hair
club for men saying i'm not only the
president i'm also a client
you apply your own lessons to your own
love life right yes how's that going
it's going great and my husband gave me
full permission to talk about it okay
you said there was no spark with your
husband you know i said it was a slow
burn
slow burn what does that mean a slow
burn is someone where
they're not shiny on the first date
they're not necessarily the most
charismatic or knock you off your feet
but the more time you spend with them
the more you like them and so wouldn't
you rather have someone that gets better
over time so yes it's honestly our
culture is very extrovert heavy it's
also for introverts some people just
take time to warm up but they're such
good partners you tell a great story
about how you got to scott because your
first guy said could you wait out to
here outside of the club so i could go
in and meet people don't come in with me
reminds me of the time logan i was
holding on to the bumper of akai's
lincoln continentals he was driving away
and i'm thinking maybe he doesn't want
to be with me
that's a true story again
yes i was younger i was younger i was
younger he drove away and i'm left in
the parking lot with all my neighbors
looking down at me i'll never forget
these are hard lessons yes these are
very hard yes my story is that i was
chasing after this guy
yeah and i went to a dating coach we
focus on what matters and what doesn't
and through that i was like this guy
from work who's been tutoring me in the
coding language he makes me feel great
he's so funny he's so kind his mom's a
therapist
i love everything about him and then we
started dating my one recommendation as
a married person is even if it's a slow
burn you read your vows at your wedding
it was a spark love it for a second
it's really good logan it's very good
it's terrific logan yuri thank you very
much the book is called how to not die
alone it will help you it's out on
paperback tomorrow and it's published by
simon and schuster a division of viacom
cbs